if you could give everyone in the world
an experiment to do for 30 days one
activity that they'd have to do every
day for 30 days what would it be oh I
would ask them to take out a piece of
paper and write down every thought that
they've been thinking that standing in
the way between their future and and
where they are write down every habit or
behavior even how they speak that stops
them from becoming the person that is
healthy wealthy or free and then to
begin to recognize the emotions that
keep them in the same state of being
every single day and become so conscious
of those thoughts behaviors and emotions
that they wouldn't let any of them slip
by unnoticed by them then I would have
them write down the thoughts they do
want to fire and wire on their brain I
would have them write down what the
behaviors look like of a great person
that they wanted to become and I would
have them practice thinking about it and
practice rehearsing it and then I would
say to them what emotions would you feel
when your future happened because you
have to teach your body emotionally what
that future feels like before it happens
and every day if you practice that
diligently and sincerely and just become
conscious of who you no longer want to
be and keep becoming conscious of who do
you do want to be that surprises you and
leaves no doubt that it's come from a
greater mind then you'll be inspired to
do it again and now we believe from one
of the creators of our lives and less of
the victims of Our Lives need motivation
watch a top 10 with believe Nation hey
it's Evan Carmichael and I make these
videos because you are probably the most
ambitious person in your circle but you
know you're capable of more and you get
that Push by surrounding yourself with
the best so today let's learn from one
of the best Joe dispenza and my take on
his top 50 rules of success enjoy
if you said well listen I'm not going to
wait for my healing
to feel gratitude I'm not going to wait
for my new relationship to feel love
I'm going to actually teach my body
emotionally what that future feels like
before it happens now
this is a big turnaround for a lot of
people because we're so reliant on the
outer World to Change our inner world
right waiting is not creating I mean
period And when people are they could
have the greatest intentions in the
world
but if they don't combine that with an
elevated emotion there's no signal
because the elevated emotion is the
carrier it's the energy that carries the
thought
so then when we're in separation in lack
waiting for our wealth to feel abundance
we're basically living our whole life in
pain right so then if you reason this
and a person can get up from their
meditation and they literally feel
differently and they're feeling the
emotions of their future before it
happens this is turning the the whole
process around
they can't be looking for it that why
would they be looking for it if they
felt like it there it already happened
now there's no separation now this is
when those serendipities and
coincidences and opportunities begin to
show up in people's lives so it's work
but then when they start seeing the
experience in their life
all of a sudden they start believing
they're more of the creator of their
life yeah and less of the victim of
their life with a community of
like-minded like like antler similar
energy of people uh everybody
understands they get one another you
know you you communities tends to be the
thing now that in terms of our social
media and the feedback we're getting
everybody wants more Community because
you get a you get a thousand people in
an audience and their energy
synchronized now you're thinking of
something so much bigger we're just
going to measure this I just talked to a
researcher yesterday we're going to
measure a thousand people when they
reach that synchronized moment when
they're we can we know that the entire
social coherence in the room is orderly
then if you're producing a Ambience
coherent magnetic field in your heart
and you're tuning into a thought or an
intent and you got a thousand people
doing that and your energy is going to
start interfering co-mingling with the
persons next to you when that energy
starts to synchronize it's going to
produce a bigger wave the higher the
amplitude the higher the wave the more
energy there is so now you have one mind
and one heart and now when it comes to
Healing others and we've done the
research on this now and we're
collecting the data that we're teaching
people how to administer
a change in energy in the person that's
laying there because it's not matter
that emits a field that's the wrong way
to think about it it's the field that
creates matter
you change the field you change matter
you're not it's not your job to change
the tumor the tumor is the illusion it's
the pattern in the field that's that
that has to be changed so once people
start reversing this then you start
seeing tumors disappearing you start
seeing blind people seeing deaf people
hearing you start seeing people with
Parkinson's disease switch on I mean you
start seeing
stage four cancer is reversing because
now they're you're you're you're
swimming Upstream you're going to the
headwaters and making that change it's
so important in that of the infinite
places you can put your attention
put it on your heart
now when you place your attention is
where you place your energy why because
we want this Center to bloom
1400 1300 different chemicals that we
store and regenerate the body let's
breathe let's open this up let's
practice this let's start learn how to
lead with our heart a different
Consciousness yeah in the beginning
it's a little difficult but you stay
with it and you practice it pedal by
pedal by pedal placing your attention
there you're putting your own life force
back into your heart you're turning your
love Inward and the body will start
responding and in a week's time if we're
doing that three times a day or over and
over again
sooner or later that thing's going to
start blooming and just like when your
sexual organs are aroused and they're
engorged with blood this Center when you
start feeling love you make a chemical
called oxytocin
oxytocin signals nitric oxide nitric
oxide signals a chemical called derived
endothelial relaxing Factor you know
what that is it causes the arteries in
your heart to literally open up so your
heart is going to be filled with blood
and oxygen and nutrients it's
physiological it's going to feel full
you're going to have a hard on your
heart is going to fill right and when
that happens
you experience a level of love
that passes all understanding you your
cup runneth over I mean it is and people
are in they're sobbing because they
realize that this this Center finally
like a child also to make sure you're
actually taking action after watching
this video I designed a special free
worksheet just for this video the
worksheet will highlight all the Lessons
Learned in this video as well as pull
out our three favorite learnings and
quotes that will inspire you to actually
do something the worksheet will also
give you space to write down what your
key takeaways are and your specific plan
of action to make sure you're getting
results if you want the worksheet
designed specifically for this video
absolutely for free there's a link in
the description below go click on it and
start building the momentum in your life
and your business I'll see you there I
think we're all faced with great
opportunities brilliantly disguised as
impossible situations and in order like
for me person and I and after looking
through your book and reading a good
portion of it I mean for me there's
there's no school of ancient wisdom that
you need to go to be initiated your life
is your initiation if you're paying
attention so we meet challenges in our
life from a certain level of mind right
a certain level of Consciousness or
unconsciousness and even Einstein said
we have to go to a greater level of
consciousness
than the Consciousness that's created
the problem well what is consciousness
Consciousness is awareness and awareness
means possibilities that you haven't
thought of before so we could we
confront problems or challenges in our
life and as a side note I was having
breakfast with a researcher just last
week who's studying what happens when we
perceive and condition in our
environment as a problem how it weakens
the organism they're measuring this and
when a person sees it as a challenge how
they draw energy they raise the energy
of their body back into order
so if we said I want to be
wealthy or I want to be healthy
well what what you want to be that
because you're not it
so the initiation of going from not it
here to it here you're going to have to
climb some steps and there's going to be
some blind spots so you try it out and
it doesn't work
well that's because there's a part of
you that's still in a habit there's part
of you that's still unconscious okay so
what is it about myself and that
circumstance
that I am feeling about that
circumstance and that feeling is causing
me to think about it so you say oh it's
impossible they'll never change I'll
hire a hitman I'll hire the mafia I'll
hire an attorney I'll have my friend's
friend to talk to him and nothing
changes right well
you're not you're not separate from that
experience you're involved in it and how
you think and how you feel broadcasts
energy into the field so your energy is
the same every day and as long as your
energy is the same nothing's going to
change in your life either and nobody
changes until they change their energy
so then
what piece of knowledge what piece of
information what would love do what
would greatness look like okay I don't
know all right well certainly somebody
in history has faced this problem
don't get on Facebook and say does
anybody have any answers don't get go
look it up and study and breed and learn
you'll own it and you'll say wow that
person that was wealthy
they've failed 500 times well hell I had
the wrong view of wealth okay then
failure is not a thing I gotta overcome
failure well yep just climb the step
yeah okay I'm reacting to that
circumstance with the same emotion that
emotion is firing the same thoughts I'm
broadcasting the same energy into the
field if I were facing that circumstance
and situation again with that person
that circumstance what do I learn from
that circumstance how could I do it
differently the next time
find out a solution and rehearse it
install the circuitry so when you get in
the circumstance you're not going to
respond in an automatic habituation yeah
now you're at a greater level of
Consciousness now you're looking at
possibilities that you weren't looking
at before because you're unconscious now
that process of trial and error is so
important in the spiritual path
how many times
do we have to forget before we remember
and then we remember and we forget again
and it takes constantly remembering
until we stop forgetting and when we get
to that point now we're conscious now
there's wisdom and wisdom is the memory
of the experience without the emotional
charge now you're ready for the new
adventure so then
people draw conclusions and say oh it's
that person that ripped me off as that
person that
what now now you don't create your
reality you only create your reality
when things are good no well somehow you
got to Tango through this somehow your
objectivity in not reacting emotionally
is going to change the energy of how you
address this situation Consciousness is
awareness awareness is paying attention
and noticing and so 95 of Who We Are by
the time we're 35 years old is a set of
unconscious automatic programs that
we've just practiced so many times that
we're not consciously thinking about
those so in order for you to change to
answer the initial question that you
asked
the first step is you got to become
conscious of your unconscious thoughts
and you gotta you gotta start looking at
those hardwired thoughts that that you
think every day that it just circuits
that have been fired and wired together
how do we do that should we write a list
at the end of the day or one of the most
common thoughts we have that day like
how does someone become aware you don't
have to do that you just have to sit
down close your eyes and not move and
then you'll get you'll you'll start
seeing what am I thinking about right
now yeah and all you want to do is
observe the thought because
when you begin to observe that thought
you're no longer the program now you're
the Consciousness observing the program
and you're starting to pull out of the
program thinking about the thinking yeah
who's doing the thinking of the thinking
about the thinking that's who you are
when you're not the program that's
awareness right you got to become aware
of how you speak how you act becomes so
conscious
so aware of it that you won't go
unconscious and let that thought or that
behavior run you you gotta say oh my God
this feeling that I've been living by
for the last 20 years is actually guilt
I didn't know it was guilt because it
just feels like me and all of a sudden
as you start becoming conscious of it
you're beginning to objectify your
subjective self you're you're pulling
out of those programs and nobody likes
to do that because it's uncomfortable
they'd rather turn on their cell phone
start texting get on the internet you
know watch TV to distract them from that
moment and that is what they have to
move through in order to get to their to
their own personal freedom so the first
step is becoming conscious and
meditation means to become familiar with
to become conscious of to to become so
conscious of your unconscious self that
you won't go unconscious to any thought
any Behavior or emotion and get ready
because it takes a tremendous amount of
energy
to do that and awareness stay conscious
to stay conscious and so
we fall from grace yeah fine you got it
you got you're awake you got another day
let's go again how often do you fall oh
my gosh I mean how many times have I
done it thousands but I'm not gonna give
up because the moments in which I do
connect or the moments that I do have
that transcendental experience
what matters the most after it when I
have that transcendental moment I look
back
and all of those difficult meditations
those difficult days and those are the
ones you remember you don't remember the
good meditations you remember the ones
where you came up against yourself and
you want to live further and you said
I'm gonna go a little further and go a
little further or you had a rough day
and you just went in and you just you at
the end of the day you surrender and you
have the classic Oh My God moment
there's no linear correlation it's just
whether you're willing to live in
creation instead of living in survival
and so
um you get better at it you know we just
get better at it and for me
um staying conscious and staying where
and staying present
is an art because you you know when
someone's present with you in your life
because they're paying attention to you
you know when they're not present with
you because they're not paying attention
to you so imagine this field of
information this this intelligence that
lives within you and I that's governing
everything material in this world it's a
self-organizing intelligence
you have access to it so you better get
present with it as well as you can get
present with anything else and just
because you can't see it doesn't mean it
doesn't exist right and that that that
realm you can't experience with your
senses you can only experience with your
awareness so then
people have to take their attention off
their bodies and go from a somebody to a
nobody take their attention off the
people in their life and go from that
they identify with and go from a someone
to a no one take their attention off the
things in their life their cell phone
their computer their car and go from
something to nothing take their
attention off where they sleep where
they work where they're sitting and go
from somewhere to Nowhere take their
attention off the predictable future and
the familiar past in time and go from
some time to no time and now if you're
taking all of your attention off of
everything material in this
three-dimensional reality now there's
only one other thing that's left that
means you're an awareness your
Consciousness and now that is the bridge
that is the door to the quantum field
and you can't enter the quantum field as
a somebody so if someone has spent their
whole life working on having the perfect
body or so much so they have so much
attention on their pain where you place
your attentions where you place your
energy it's going to take some work for
them to take all of their attention off
their body right because they'll go
they'll do it and then they'll go back
let's see if the Pain's still there oh
the Pain's still there so it's a little
bit of a waltz in the beginning but as
people start applying this you start
getting better at it let's demystify
meditation because it has so many
stigmas around it close your eyes
Retreat from your life disconnect from
your body disconnect from your
environment disconnect from your
schedule and just give yourself an hour
or 45 minutes or 20 minutes because when
you invest in yourself you invest in
your future and when you believe in
yourself you believe in possibilities
and when you believe in possibilities
you believe in yourself and if you don't
believe in possibilities then you don't
believe in yourself and you don't
believe in yourself you don't believe in
possibilities so then but if you have a
community a living organism yeah where
it's becoming The New Normal yes you
want to join that living organism and
you want to you want to be a part of
that and and every every stride you make
feeds the living organism every stride
every effort you make
to connect is is amazing because that
which we are seeking is seeking us it's
not like it is it matches our efforts
and so then when when people have that
uncompromising will the same way that
they go shopping for a dress or a pair
of earrings or go to the gym and work
out with the same intensity with the
same passion
come up against themselves and just say
when the body's going given everything
it has it's when you say that's all you
got that's it that's all you're going to
put out to I'm ready and so then
when you start overcoming that the side
effect of it is that all of a sudden
you're happy for no reason and you're
less seduced in believing that something
else you need something outside of it
outside of you to make you feel better
all of a sudden you're feeling better
every day without anything outside of
you and now all of a sudden you start
showing up unpredictable in your life
you're saying that Ed guy he's different
he's on a different medication
but in actuality you're just Freer right
and so so then as we begin to remove
these layers that stop the flow of the
Divine in us that that in essence in us
the side effect is we become more
willful become more mindful become more
conscious we become more loving it's
it's nature you know it's just it just
it comes becomes who we are at the end
of the day if you really wanted to be
wealthy say
how did I do today did I make the right
choices what was I ethical was I Purpose
Driven was I was I was I interested in
making a difference was I fair was I
tempered uh did I really think before I
spoke what what did I remember reading
about that book about that person that
did it how'd I do and if you said I when
did I fall from grace when did I lose it
okay I want that opportunity again
I want another shot at that and I'm
going in this way what would love do in
this situation what would greatness do
and now you you evolve your experience
and somehow there's a door there's an
opening something shifts something's
changing and now here we go we climb
another ladder and then all of a sudden
there's another challenge and then
people who finally arrive at their
abundance they could care less if
they're abundant they're already knowing
that they've earned the right for it so
so there's sometimes a shortcut in the
process if we're if we really learn and
we really get it but the trial and error
is so important because
not only is the person earning the right
to be wealthy but they're earning the
right to live in worthiness worthy to
receive like hey you people people come
to our work all the time for a lot of
reasons and one of the common reasons is
they want to get healthy yeah and and
they're ill because they're dealing with
a very serious health condition and I
would say the same thing to them
stop wanting to be healthy learn the
formula yeah on how to get healthy learn
the formula on how to heal and the
healing will be the side effect of it if
you're obsessing about why am I not
healed you're still the old person
you're going to become that person every
day right turns out that when you sit
down
and the people that we interview that
have had significant changes
when it's no longer about their health
but they are they are out of the
bleachers and they're on the playing
field and they are coming up against the
belief like one lady said God I I always
thought that this work really worked
that this these concepts are the truth
but I never believed it worked for me
and I was in a car accident I'm in a
wheelchair and then she made the
decision that she was going to overcome
that belief now it was no longer about
her healing it was about overcoming the
belief which overcame the belief and I
showed up every day for herself when you
believe in yourself you believe in
possibilities When You Believe in
possibilities you got to believe in
yourself you don't show up for yourself
you don't believe in it yeah and and
that's why people don't do the work I
mean if you you believe that your
thoughts create a reality you would show
up every day and create and so a lot of
people believe in their past more than
they believe in their future a lot of
people fall in love or more in love with
their past or romance their past instead
of romance their future or love their
future it's it's that simple so
the initiation process of life is always
going to be there you're always going to
be challenged if if you want to be a
master well then you better learn how to
heal someone else and you're going to
fail a lot of times and if you think
that you're a failure then you'll quit
but if you feel like you just didn't
quite ding it yet and you show up again
to just ding it and you keep evolving
your experience and go deeper how much
more can I open my heart how much more
can I Surrender into this infinite field
how much more can I become can I walk as
it with my eyes open people do
meditations and they have great
meditations me included and then you get
up you open your eyes and you're back in
the program and people want to know why
they haven't healed and we have
testimonies of people they're speaking
the truth they said my Ms my rheumatoid
and my lupus never went away
and great meditations I felt better
and then I realized with my eyes open I
was still that person and now next level
they're in the game and catching
themselves or catching how they speak
they're watching how they think they're
not letting their body fall in the same
emotional state to put them in the same
past experience that the body's
believing in now this is the this is the
great part and when a person finally
breaks through from the chains
and there's a different consciousness of
Freedom that happens they look back at
their past they want to change one thing
in their past because it brought them to
that present moment that's the path no
longer existing that's the freedom so is
it worth the effort yeah it's no longer
about healing it's no longer about
abundance it's about who you're becoming
I will never work in a relationship I
just won't if I'm working in a
relationship something's wrong I work on
me and I'll bring my best you bring your
best and we get together and we
celebrate it should work it should work
and if it doesn't then I'm gonna step
back and see what is it about me not you
what is it about me that I need to
really look at and change now if there's
a vibrational match and it flows and
it's fun and you connect on
physically mentally Mind Body Soul you
know that's cool I think that's healthy
uh uh but a mission-driven person can't
be in a relationship where you have to
keep going back and and trying to fix
something I just I just won't do that I
just think that when it when it's right
it's right and I'll know
yeah yeah so I think that I do think
that uh
relationships can be easy and I I do
think I I and I think that they should
be and I and I think that if you're
heart centered that's a different place
you meet uh than than other emotions and
and I and I and again every time I have
a mystical moment
and I feel that transcendental love that
I don't even know the word for uh every
time I have one of those moments I think
I got this all wrong it's just that it
it's it is not chemical it's electric
and you got what all wrong
well the way we view the world the way
we pres I mean we don't see things how
they are we see things how we are you
know in every inner experience that's
transcendental experience and riches
circuitry in your brain experience
produces emotion or energy in the body
so you start having transcendental
moments where you start connecting to
that field its signature is love I mean
but not love like a love for your puppy
it's just like this is like an arousal
this is I don't know the other word but
spiritual arousal yeah and we have the
we have the evidence we can say
oh watch this watch this person's brain
and scientists are studying our work
I'll say oh um watch she's gonna pop in
a few minutes what do you mean just
watch she's gonna pop and all of a
sudden this person goes into an arousal
the sympathetic nervous system is so
switched on but the arousal isn't like
an arousal that from the environment
that produces anger or aggression or
fear anxiety or pain or suffering that's
Survival in the environment that
produces the rattle this arousal is
coming from energy in the body that's
moving up into the brain and
the arousal was Bliss the arousal is
ecstasy the arousal is freedom but it's
it's not chemical it's it's you'll feel
it in every single cell in your body now
here's the outcome of that the outcome
of that is that when you open your eyes
and some conditioning some layer has
been removed
your spectrum of the way the world looks
broadens now because now you're wired to
perceive what's always existed
but you didn't have the circuits in
place to perceive them so then it's the
inner experience that literally trans
transforms our experience of the outer
world and so when you start having
moments where you hit that kind of
frequency or you have those moments of
love
you're less dependent on anyone to bring
you happiness you're you're okay you can
love the person for their flaws because
you can see a part of yourself you used
to be that you no longer aren't instead
of judgment you have compassion and you
can encourage and and and communicate
from a from a level of connection
instead of intimidation or or
competition or however relationships
Works what are the three things we
should say when we wake up in the
morning well think well first I would
say what is the greatest ideal of myself
that I can be today and I would not get
up until I felt like that person
the second thing I would say is can I
begin to keep my energy up the entire
day and if I do it properly then I will
be open to Opportunities and
possibilities that weren't there before
the last thing I would say is could I
sustain brain and heart coherence to the
point where that intelligence within me
that's giving me life begins to find the
door to open out so I can begin to see
evidence in my world what would you say
every evening before you go to sleep oh
yeah how did I do how did I do how did I
do today I mean one day one lifetime
yeah how did I do today did I change or
help another human being did I really
change someone's future or future
timeline lastly what is the greatest
thing I learned you think
60 to 70 000 thoughts in one day
out of those sixty to seventy thousand
thoughts that you think in one day
ninety percent of those thoughts are the
same thoughts as the day before
so if you believe that your thoughts
somehow are connected to your life
then the same thoughts always lead to
the same choices
the same choices always lead to the same
behaviors
the same behaviors create the same
experiences
and the same experiences produce the
same emotions
and those very same emotions Drive the
very same thoughts
and your biology
your neural circuitry your
neurochemistry your neural hormones
and even your genetic expression
is equal to how you think how you act
and how you feel
and how you think how you act and how
you feel is called your personality
and your personality creates your
personal reality
that's it
so then if you wanted to create a new
personal reality
a new life
then you would have to start thinking
about what you've been thinking about
and change it
you would have to become aware of your
unconscious thoughts and observe them
you would have to pay attention to your
automatic habits and behaviors and
modify them
and you would have to look at the
emotions you live by every single day
that are connected to your past
and decide if those emotions belong in
your future
you see most people try to create a new
personal reality as the same personality
and it doesn't work
you literally have to become someone
else I believe in Free Will I would
never tell anybody what to believe like
politically or socially or whatever I I
want to provide them the tools and give
them the free will to create life
however they want and believe whatever
they want that's totally cool with me so
those people then
that want to be healed
and they live in fear
that fear has to be addressed I mean and
it's not easy because it's it's
hardwired deep in the limbic brain it's
just a safety net it's a mechanism so
then imagine being in the unknown
if the the Instinct and the unknown is
it's a Scary Place wow imagine not
having a body and we practice lingering
without a body in in in an infinite
space and not without a name without a
face without a culture without a job
without a social security number without
a disease without a diet just as an
awareness you you practice that
you're going to be comfortable in the
unknown you're going to relax more into
it that's going against
thousands of years of programming and
the people who actually overcome their
fear
and they traded for gratitude their
immune system gets stronger uh their
genes up regulate I mean there's just a
host of CR uh everything their brain
changes their heart rate variability
they feel differently and it's it's
being measured and some of these people
we're measuring this now in our in our
events with with reputable scientists in
in universities they're they're
shocked at what they're witnessing on a
cellular level on a brain level on a
heart level
they cannot believe
the capacity of the body I it just was I
just got an email today of assign one of
our scientists said I ran this
three times
the virus that we exposed the cell to in
advance meditators does not enter the
cell it's outside the cell it won't a
virus and novice meditators some of it's
in the cell some of itself controls all
the viruses in the cell there's an
immunity so when the person's less
reactionary to their environment there's
less of response that weakens them
they're less of a victim to their
environment then they're less of a
victim to their environment
large-scale small scale the body has a
greater immunity to whatever it is Bond
University a university in Australia on
the Gold Coast
senior researcher took a large majority
of my brain scans
and they hadn't she had them analyzed by
her graduate students and they
statistically looked at everything
one of the most startling things for the
research team was our community's
ability
to go to to get to that point where
they're nobody no one no thing nowhere
no time I'm talking four seconds I'm
talking five seconds I'm talking nine
seconds just like just give me a second
I know how to do this they they've
practiced it enough times that the
creative moment is when you get Beyond
yourself when you dissociate from
everything known in your Material World
Turns out when you do that and you start
changing your brain waves
your brain waves slow down into Alpha
and Theta you're suppressing the memory
bank of the known self that keeps you
plugged into three-dimensional reality
when you quiet down this mechanism
now all of a sudden you start connecting
to that field and when you can stay
conscious in those subconscious Realms
when you can literally regulate and
change brain waves now you're in the
operating system where you can make
those significant changes here's the
deal with trauma and it's kind of an
interesting thing because when you're
traumatized some threat or some danger
or some condition in your outer world
through your senses is changing how you
feel in your inner world and the
quotient of change between the way you
normally feel in some alarm State when
you change your internal State and move
into that emergency mode you narrow your
focus on the cause and the Brain
freezes an image and takes a snapshot
and that's called the long-term memory
and now that image is branded
holographically into the brain so then
they remember experiment our experiences
better because we can remember how they
feel and and that memory then changes
the person's biology so they think
neurologically within the circuits of
that experience and they feel chemically
within the boundaries of those emotions
and how we think and feel becomes our
state of being so so now the person
biologically is changed and many times
it's the strong emotion that begins to
select and instruct the gene that
creates disease why because if the
environment signals the Gene and that's
a truth that's epigenetics and the end
product of an experience in the
environment is an emotion the emotion
that you feel from that event is
literally selecting the gene gosh for
you to begin to change and the genes
make proteins and so the the person if
it's if it's strong enough begins to
wear their trauma not just in their
brain now it's in their body because
every time they think about that trauma
every time they review it every time
they keep creating the imagery they keep
firing and wiring the circuits in their
brain and they keep feeling the feeling
emotionally in their body and their body
is so objective that it's believing it's
living in the same past experience 50 to
100 times a day and all you need is a
stimulus in a response an image and an
emotion a thought and a feeling and
you're conditioning the body into the
past well you're conditioning the brain
body into the bad why is our memory
for
pain stronger than our memory of a
success or a joy I really think that
when the survival Gene is activated
preservation is the key so we can have
10 things
that happen really great in our lives
you have a family member or somebody you
know that does this they have cr 10
really great things happen in their one
thing bed and they focus on that bad
thing why because the survival genes
activated they want to make sure it
doesn't happen again so so you put your
attention on it because you don't want
it to happen again so what people do
when they're aroused is they start
thinking it's going to happen so they
actually select the worst
case scenario in their mind and then
emotionally Embrace that future before
it happens and they're conditioning
their body it's become the mind of
anxiety and fear so in preservation and
in survival if you prepare for the worst
anything less that happens you have a
better chance of surviving so that's the
mechanism that takes place so
survival means you better take care of
your body yeah you better be aware of
your environment and make sure there's
no threats and so you got to keep your
eye out there
and you better be thinking about the
future based on what you learned in the
past now there's nothing wrong with that
when the analytical facilities are in
Balance but when there's an arousal
arousal there's three things that create
arousal fear
hostility and anger or aggression and
pain
and that arousal drives the brain
into these high states of what we call
High beta and most people need something
or someone or some circumstance or some
drug or some pill or some computer game
to change that internal State and the
moment they notice a change in their
Eternal safe and they pay attention to
what's causing it they start developing
a dependency on it right so
turns out that when we teach people how
to self-regulate and change their brain
waves we could actually see then that
the incoherence that disorderliness
that's taking place in the brain you
know when you're over aroused you're
overly analytical and you're shifting
your attention from one problem to one
person to one thing to one place to
another problem to another circumstance
to your phone to your car and each one
of those elements has a neurological
Network in the brain so the arousal
causes these different circuits to fire
out of order and the brain is incoherent
so take two waves that are out of phase
and mix them when they interfere they
flatten out there's no energy so energy
leaves the brain right
so then
when you're in arousal you narrow your
focus on the cause if there is something
rattling in the bushes and it's dark you
freeze and you narrow your focus on it
and there's a rush of adrenaline and
your pupils dilate and your heart starts
to race and you're ready to run fight or
hide I mean that's a survival moment but
what if it's your co-worker sitting
right next to you or six feet away and
and you're judging them you're the same
arousals taking place so what's once
very adaptive becomes very maladaptive
this is where it gets challenging so
when we teach people how to open their
focus we've done thousands and thousands
of brain scans and they get beyond their
analytical processes and they open their
awareness and go from a conversion Focus
to a divert and focus and they learn how
to relax and regulate their brain waves
start to slow down into Alpha and then
if they do it properly and they're
connecting
those different compartments of the
brain that were once firing out of order
start to unify different communities
form bigger communities the brains
starts to synchronize and then all of a
sudden you start seeing different
compartments of the brain all in
resonance so now when they're all in
resonance and they start interfering
when those waves come together there's
more energy in the brain so when a
person dials down the mechanism this
neocortex that plugs us into
three-dimensional reality that keeps us
aware of our body that's the
autobiographical self where everything's
stitched in memory in there when we
start deactivating the mechanism here
and we get beyond the memory bank of the
known self and brain waves move into
Theta we we've studied this so much
when a person can let their body
be in a light state of sleep and feel so
safe
that you can finally let go and
surrender the body is sleeping but the
mind is awake and now the door between
the conscious mind and the subconscious
mind is wide open and if they can
regulate and stay there
something amazing happens
there is a release of energy
from the body and their brain goes into
a very very super coherent state of
gamma and Gamma is super Consciousness
now I'm not talking about
a little camera I'm not talking about a
lot of gamma I'm not talking about a
really loud camera I'm talking about a
supernatural amount of gamma
so there's so much order
and so much energy in the brain like if
we were in an audience and we were all
clapping like this
that could be Alpha right Theta would be
and if everybody could do this it's
slower we could do it the more we can
get our timing down the more we can get
coherent but if we were doing
this would be really hard for all of us
to do that at the same time so it takes
a lot of order a lot of awareness a lot
of energy to be able to create that kind
of order so
that's how fast the brain is in that
arousal
that's taking place is ecstasy that
arousal is bliss it is the most familiar
unfamiliar feeling that people ever have
and that memory then that the person has
that is so profoundly different than the
feeling of success
the feeling of wealth the feeling of
orgasm or love or whatever this is a new
one and it's a thrill
and the person notices a dramatic change
in their inner State and with that
experience comes a very lucid picture a
very profound Insight a download of
information
that's the moment then the body many
times rewrites the biological program
energy
is informing matter and the autonomic
nervous system is regulating it's in
high order and remember disease is
autonomic dysregulation now it's getting
into a very very high frequency of order
and it's sending very coherent
information to the cells and tissues
sending energy to the cells and tissues
and cells begin to emit more coherent
light and information and then there's
the disease
and there it's not the recognition that
when you're assimilating a negative
thought or a negative judgment or a
negative emotion Envy greed whatever it
may be that's actually lowering your
energy yeah and when you get to that
place where you're experiencing that
incredible Bliss right here you can't
you can't yeah and even if you have the
thought the thought will still come
because we still have those thoughts
that's the thought will be an
understanding correct human nature
because you're no longer at that
vibrational level anymore are you Rising
above it you know and and I think more
and more people are starting to figure
that out and and and the people in their
lives are like no my husband my husband
is a changed person no he's not the same
guy I know him I know he's completely
different and the guy's just like yeah I
feel amazing I feel great and all it was
was sitting in the fire yes for a little
bit of time to the body finally moved
out of the past into the present moment
and so
the causes of this like I always say you
never know
what you're doing today and how you're
doing it who you're going to affect
tomorrow when you do this work and
that's what we're seeing people are
they're they're they're they're getting
promotions uh they're getting all these
wonderful things not because of anything
that they're doing they're just
different yeah and people notice that
and they want those people in the
position to make better decisions for
the whole and I think that's uh that's
how we change the world in our community
at least people who have relationships
that are built from our community tend
to be more long-lasting because they're
more self-aware and so there's no blame
there's no excuses there's no make wrong
there's no competition there's none of
that there's just this is who I am you
know and I think that the ultimate goal
is when you reach the point in your life
when how you appear to the world is who
you really are that level of
transparency is it takes no effort right
you can be yourself and and and you know
people say to me wow you're you're
pretty approachable and I say okay well
God I work so hard every day on
overcoming myself in the morning
overcoming my ego why would I want to
build it up the next day because I gotta
face that guy again tomorrow morning so
why not just keep you know you know
taking those edges and smoothing them
down so that so that
you're you're less unconscious to all of
those programs that are built in
relationships you asked if is it
possible then can that people can heal
that quickly in one week yeah because
what if they create an inner event
that carries an amplitude of gratitude
or Joy or Freedom breakthrough from the
chains of the past when the body is
liberated and you feel that elevated
emotion the stronger the emotion you
feel from that breakthrough the more
you're going to pay attention to the
image in your mind and now you're now
beginning to brand new circuitry in the
brain and your body's being conditioned
into a new future and the stronger the
emotion you feel the more you pay
attention to the picture the more you're
conditioning the body over time to the
Future instead of the past so now
you keep knocking on that genetic door
emotionally then that emotion ultimately
signals a new Gene that up regulates
that genes produce better proteins and
the person and all of a sudden starts
healing and we have researched to show
that people can do that in four days
signal genes to reduce cancer cells wow
just to Signal stem cells to to suppress
um uh to go to active tissues and repair
them and regenerate them and suppress
inflammation you come with a lot of
genes and they're just a library of
potentials they're just a storehouse of
information of possibilities so then you
got to get the right signal the right
lock into the key that begins to select
and instruct genes that cause genes to
make different proteins and you can
regulate so many different genes the
same genes you can regulate them
differently so when they up regulate
they start producing really healthy and
robust proteins and that's that's
enzymes that's tissue that structure
that's function that's harm
it's immune immunoglobulins when they
down regulate because of some alarm when
there's not a lot of energy
for long-term building projects well
then you keep doing that then the body
starts producing cheaper proteins it's a
different signal it's not a time for
growth when you hit Pay Dirt like that
when you connect when you connect to the
field when you connect the Divine
whatever you want to call it when your
Consciousness merges with a greater
Consciousness and that arousal creates
ecstasy Bliss Oneness whatever you want
to call that
you realize that it never came from
anything out there it didn't come from
the Wardrobe or the facelift the sports
car whatever
it came from within you and so you stop
looking out there for it and now the
love affair begins and you never want to
miss a date because it's just too good
so that memory then that is what I'm
after because when you have those
transcendental moments and you
understand this yeah
the experience of that transcendental
moment
lays down new circuitry and the praying
that's what experience does and the
experience produces a feeling but it's
not chemical it's electric and it's
orderly and every cell of your body is
jiggling in an order and they're and
you're aroused and you're awakened right
you have to admit when that occurs your
spectrum of reality is going to broaden
some conditioning some illusion
something is removed and you start
seeing reality as it is and all of a
sudden you start seeing the part that we
edit out for survival now you start
seeing patterns and lights and
information
that are Transcendent of
three-dimensional reality in your
spectrum why because your brain had the
experience and the circuitry is there
and now your your experience of the
world changes you get an upgrade to the
to the VR set the virtual reality said
oh you got the upgrade you got 2.0 and
now it looks different everything looks
different everybody looks different in
the world look you're seeing Beauty more
well and there's more holism and more
connection and sounds and words and
music and sense and sight and light is
all working together uh I mean that's
the blessing of an Awakening right
that's where that's where we're going
what do you think the world Humanities
challenge will be over the next decade
as we enter 2020.
um back to the principle Louis of just
different paradigms beginning to
collapse you know economically
politically socially environmentally
religiously the education journalism the
uh you know medicine
um they they have to uh move into chaos
and chaos is just unpredictable not
working yeah exactly but now here's the
challenge for Humanity you have one of
two ways to embrace the breakdown of
those those paradigms you can face them
with anger and hostility and fear and
you are only contributing to more of it
we have to see that those breakdowns are
essential for something greater to
happen now
we can't wait
for governments to take care of us
that's we can't wait for
medicine to to give us a drug that's
going to heal us from a condition
the truth is with a greater level of
consciousness
the change in Awareness because of
information
the greatest challenge we have is those
as those paradigms break down is to no
longer emotionally react in the same way
and be victims you can't say this
President this person this this whatever
is actually making me feel this way and
think this way basically you're in the
program that you're something outside of
you is controlling you how you feel and
how you think so then to self-regulate
then is to say how I think and feel was
going to change my outer environment so
then
we're all faced with great opportunities
brilliantly disguised as impossible
situations and we are at that point at
that Nexus point in our Evolution as a
species so then you don't try to fix
that that's never going to work what you
do is you create something better and
then everybody just naturally just
leaves that and goes here now it used to
be some people would just come here and
the majority would stay here because
they're clinging to what they've been
programmed or believing but now
because of information everybody's like
that's not gonna work I already know
it's not going to work and I don't care
what anybody says this is working for me
so
people are moving to new to new um to
new applications to new paradigms
because it's working for them so as long
as we don't emotionally react to the
breakdown that's happening currently in
the world and chaos is just
unpredictable order you know as as as
things move towards disorder the novelty
that's being created is literally chaos
because the known and everything's
staying the same is order but as you
step out into that unknown it's then
you're having the chaos is unpredictable
order being expressed through novelty
and we have to be able to learn how to
take that disorder and what the
application of brain and heart coherence
create more order so you can't just say
hey I'm standing up for peace and you
know and being being miserable with your
co-worker you you you don't get to talk
about peace and so there's you you are
the you're the Living Prayer of Peace
not just we know we know crime rates go
down and
violence goes down when there's peace
projects and communities where there's
meditation on peace but when those peace
Gathering projects end you know you see
that crime and violence and everything
returns back to the same level so it's
not enough to just think it we got to
demonstrate it so if I'm demonstrating
peace and you're demonstrating peace
somebody else because of mere neurons is
going to go wow that person's
unpredictable wow they're different it's
given me permission to do the same
so I think that ultimately moving into
that state of being you know as human
beings and and and creating Unity that
you know you keep watching so many
programs on television that talk you
into Prejudice that talk you into
separation that talk you into fear that
talk you into violence that talk you
into war deceit uh negativity
um you're you're not going to trust
anybody in fact you're going to see
difference between you and me or anybody
because that's what separation does but
when your heart's centered and you feel
connected you don't see the person any
longer right you see something
transcending them you see in essence
right and I think if you do that really
well
that kind of emergence of a of a new
consciousness
that's less dependent on on all of those
outer things it's really difficult to
control and if you want to control a
community control their emotions and
control them in survival when you
overcome your emotions you can see the
hidden meaning behind all things and
when everybody's looking this way you
may be looking that way because you
understand look you've just overcome
your fear you just overcome your
hostility and anger you've overcome the
program of whatever it is I swear to you
you're going to be able to connect
people and that that then is the hope of
the future if you're alive in this world
and you haven't been experiencing the
quickening I mean I mean you know I said
to uh someone the other day
the day where you end your day and Feel
Complete because you finished all your
work you'll never have that and you know
there's always more emails and more
things to check right so the demand has
has has pressed us into this crazy realm
of of uh of of um multitasking and I
think that you start shifting where you
place your attention is where you place
your energy so if you're shifting your
attention all over the board your energy
is scattered yeah so then when you start
disconnecting from everybody your boss
your co-worker you know the news your
cell phone your computer and you start
going this way
I think it's uh into the present moment
than of where you place your attention
is where you place your energy and
you're truly in the present moment
you've got a lot of energy to execute
got a lot of energy to use and you want
to be able to do that eyes open the more
scattered your energy the less you have
to focus on pushing one thing forward
that's why people's dreams don't happen
because they're scattered there's no
look look if you keep putting your
attention on some future experience that
you are imagining with your mind your
body is going to follow your mind right
there because that's where your energy
is but if you're putting your attention
on everything known in your life the
shower the coffee maker you know the
toilet and your body's following your
mind every day to the known but we want
your body to follow your mind to the
unknown right enough people get to doing
that and you could do better in creating
things in your life that we see this
wealthy people in our work that are
focused on well some of them living in
the back seat of their car some of them
bankrupt that now have multi-million
dollar companies what do you think they
want to do with that money
they want to give it away get back let
me tell you why not because of any other
reason is that they now know that they
create more right well why why if you're
abundant why abundance to me has changed
abundance means I have more than I need
like way more than I need so if I have
way more than I need and I know how to
create it
then take it I'll create more of it so
now you're no longer holding on in
scarcity
you're making a difference so wealthy
people that have created a lot of wealth
in this work they want to give back they
want to make a difference and I think
that that's how we're innately wired I
think we're all innately wired to care
for one another to make a difference in
the living organism our living organism
our community we heal one another that's
what we do right we inform one another
we encourage one another we support one
another we shine for one another not to
outshine another person to shine to show
them if they can shine and that's that
to me is super healthy so then I'm I'm
applauding your success because I want
you to succeed because you're telling me
that if you can do it I can do it so so
there's no longer any separation I think
that's hopeful for the world and you
start celebrating diversity then you're
like wow you're way different than me I
wanna I wanna study you because I want
to bring that into who I'm becoming and
you create a strong community that way
what are the things that
disturb or
disconnect our Awakening and connection
to the Divine a lot of times when people
they hit that point they try to
reproduce it the same way as we talked
about and you can't yeah you can't do it
the same way because that's redundancy
but also many times we have the
experience and we start to try and
because trying is matter trying to
change matter and and so we're forcing
we're controlling we're predicting and
and then the uh and when we do that then
of course we're in separation and we're
waiting for the event to happen to feel
the emotion right and I've done that
long enough and is actually have to lay
down
the very thing we used our whole life to
get what we want for something greater
to occur and it takes practice of
surrender right so
that's one element I also think that our
response is emotionally like uh uh uh
let's just say that a person gets
connected to the Future they get
connected to the energy of their future
they feel it it's really great and then
they start their day and then two hours
later they're they're feeling something
else because some person or some
circumstance altered their state well
they just disconnected from the energy
of the future and now they're back to
the energy of the past don't expect
anything to change in your life because
it doesn't work that way so then then
when they get back to that old self
again then they say what's wrong with me
I fail they didn't do it right no that's
all the program you show up again and
you go after it again
so familiar feelings uh cause us
to no longer see through the lens of the
future we're seeing through the lens of
the past and and and we color reality
that way so
um I think I think familiar emotions uh
could get in the way as well and then of
course there's always belief and a
belief is just a thought you keep
thinking over and over again until you
hardwired in your brain and all beliefs
are based on past experience a person
has an experience the stronger the
emotion they have from that circumstance
the more they pay attention to the cause
and the brain freezes a frame takes a
snapshot and it's called the memory the
moment they draw a conclusion about that
experience they'll think neurologically
within those circuits and they'll feel
chemically within the boundaries of
emotion thinking and feeling thinking
and feeling belief becomes an
unconscious or subconscious state of
being they don't most people don't even
know they have beliefs about things
about God about relationships about
money because it's it's not a conscious
thing it's a subconscious thing yeah so
in order to change a belief or a
perception
about yourself and your life
you got to go all in it's not like you
go 50 in you got to go all in you got to
make a decision
with such firm intention
that the amplitude of that decision
carries a level of energy
that causes the body to respond to the
mind that the choice that you make
becomes a moment in time you'll never
forget and you would say I remember the
moment
I made up my mind to change and the
stronger the emotion you feel the more
you'll pay attention to the decision and
that's a huge Stone you drop in the
quantum field Big Splash big waves your
brain is organized to reflect everything
you know in your life
your brain is a record of the past
it's an artifact
of all the things you've learned and
experienced to this moment
so if you wake up every morning
and get out of bed on the same side
shut the alarm clock off with the same
finger
Shuffle into the bathroom and use the
toilet like you always do
go and get a cup of coffee and drink
coffee out of your favorite mug
then get in the shower and wash yourself
off in the same routine way
drive to work
get to work see the same people
that push the same emotional buttons
do the same things that you've memorized
and do so well
then hurry up and go home
and hurry up and check your emails and
hurry up and check your Facebook and
then watch your favorite television show
then hurry up and go to bed
here's my question
did your brain change at all that day
we could say that you were thinking the
same thoughts performing the same
unconscious actions living by the same
emotions but secretly expecting your
life to change
so there's a principle in neuroscience
and the principle says nerve cells that
fire together wire together
so if you're thinking the same thoughts
making the same choices demonstrating
the same behaviors
reproducing the same experiences that
stamp the same networks of neurons into
the same patterns
and then produce the same emotions
you're going to hardwire your brain
into a very finite signature
because as you fire and wire the same
circuits in the same way those circuits
begin to become more connected
and by the time you're 35 years old this
is science now
we become a set of memorized behaviors
unconscious habits automatic emotional
reactions beliefs and perceptions and
even attitudes that function just like a
computer program
and if you do something over and over
and over again the repetition of those
actions over time conditions your body
to know how to do it well better than
your mind
and a habit is when your body knows
better than your mind where you've done
something so many times that the body
now knows how to do it better than the
brain
and so 95 of most people's behaviors
attitudes thoughts beliefs emotional
reactions or subconscious programs
so why is that important
because you're here this week
to learn new information
and every time you learn something new
you make new Connections in your brain
that's what learning is
learning is forging new synaptic
connections
physical evidence
as a result of your interaction in the
environment
and the footprints of Consciousness is
called learning making new connections
and the Nobel Prize Laureate candel in
the year 2000
found that when people learned one bit
of information
they doubled the number of Connections
in their brain from thirteen hundred
connections to 2600 connections
but if they didn't review that
information if they couldn't repeat it
if they couldn't remember it those
circuits pruned the part in hours or
days
so if learning is making new synaptic
connections then remembering is
maintaining and sustaining those
connections your body rejects viruses
all the time of course it has memorized
certain viruses that you've been exposed
to it's memorized certain bacteria that
you've been exposed to and it's beaten
those viruses it's not every virus wins
in the body the body has an intelligence
and it's and it has quite a library of
memories in the in the in the white
blood cells so your body is fighting
viruses and bacteria all the time
there's got constant competition going
on really so our research shows that
four days
of opening your heart releases
immunoglobulin a your body's primary
defense against bacteria and viruses
it's better than the flu shot it's the
body's natural flu shot and that's the
innate intelligence of body saying I got
this I got a lot of energy in fact I got
a surplus of energy in fact I'm
radiating energy and now there's not too
much out of the world it will now my
outer world is not controlling my inner
world my inner world now is functioning
independent of what's going on in my
outer world and now my manifesting
you're manifesting ah now you got it now
you're in a creative state because
people are coming to you yes right
exactly now you're a magnet now you have
a field right and you have energy to
heal and our research shows that that
field around your body will actually
expand you you radiate more light in
information cells are getting new
information that that are causing uh um
light to be exchanged between cells and
information now the body's getting an
upgrade so so that immunoglobulin a in
four days went up 50 percent
so now we now know that if it's going up
50 that then the immune system was
getting a new signal and nitric oxide
then causes another chemical to activate
the arteries in your heart to swell and
now just like when energy moves into
your sexual organs and it swells of
blood and you have energy there the same
intensity it moves into your heart and
now
now the heart is activated and what do
you feel you feel an incredible amount
of Love yeah you feel you feel whole and
now the more whole you feel our research
shows then the less separate you feel
from the things you want in your life
because you feel like you already have
them you only want things when you're in
lack but when you feel whole then it
feels like it's already happened and
that tends to be the exact emotion that
causes those synchronicities and
serendipities and coincidences to happen
in our life and you say to a person what
are you doing and they're saying I'm not
doing anything I'm I'm just loving life
I'm being myself yeah I'm free I'm free
from the past I'm free from my story of
the past time in fact I'm more connected
to the energy of my future than I am to
the energy of my past I think that if we
share the same experiences because we
like the same things we share the same
emotions and if we share the same
experiences we share the same emotions I
can relate to you so we can exchange
ideas and information
and if we share the same energy energy
is information so many people as an
example
they use each other to reaffirm their
their dependency on suffering so I
suffer more than you than you say I you
I suffer from you suffer more than me we
have this thing we just complain with
each other well that's the same
resonance the same frequency and there's
a match right but goes to the same means
if you if you're if you're someone who's
has a accountability partner that that
you exchange ideas like this with and
it's a different frequency and different
energy so when energy comes together as
constructive something comes out of it
yeah you feel it right it's and then you
feel in elevation if there's dissonance
then your your sensing meter is how you
feel about that person many times in
your gut or in your heart or wherever
and there's Decon there's a destructive
interference and there's no energy
involved so I think that's just a
practice but really the ultimate mastery
is to be able to be in such a resonance
such coherence that when you walk in the
room that you raise
everybody's energy and you don't let
your energy drop because of any
circumstance or any condition and that
would be greater than your environment
right and that's that's the model that
we use so imagine 1500 people in an
event where everybody's getting super
coherent and the interference that's
going on in the room is creating these
high amplitudes now we've measured that
in the room and the energy in the room
is
off the chart many times there's I mean
there's energy for healing in there
there's energy for all kinds of things
that can happen so we brought it to life
with our awareness and so
the more elevated the emotion love
gratitude Freedom Bliss ecstasy the
higher the frequency so but it turns out
you could have a collective group of
people with a lot of energy and being
coherent and it creates entropy yeah you
could have a smaller group of people
that are highly coherent and put out a
very big signal so when we see a
collective really get coherent
wow the energy in the room opens up
doors
of possibilities that I would I would
never expect I mean I I don't I don't
know how to explain some of the
phenomenological things that happen
but that's that's everybody's Divine
like everybody's everybody's in that
state they're they're in that elevated
state so
I think our I think our truth meter is
really whether we feel it lifted uh or
we feel like we've been robbed if you
are not defined by some vision
that is bigger than you
and you are not passionate about that
Vision then you're left with the old
Hardware of the past in your brain and
you will be predictable in your life
so would you agree then
new thoughts
new information should lead to new
choices
new choices should lead to new behaviors
and new behaviors should create new
experiences
and new experiences should produce new
emotions and those new emotions should
drive new thoughts and that's called
evolution
so if your brain is a record of the past
and you don't have a vision of the
future
then you are living in the past
and you will never arrive at that new
future if you have been an experienced
uh if you had experience of trauma say
for example and it's created the feeling
of fear and your fears that it could
happen again
and you're you don't know this but every
time you think about that future that
possible worst case scenario scenario
and you feel the emotion you're
conditioning your body to become the
Mind subconsciously of anxiety
so now all you need now is some cue in
your outer environment that says it's
unsafe that if there's damage there that
you're you're a victim something's
bigger than you that could have an
effect on you well now that feeling of
fear is going to cause you to think
thoughts equal to it so the person then
no longer needs the environment to feel
that fear they just have to have the
thought about that condition now and now
they're literally knocking their brain
and body out of balance by thought alone
and the body's constantly living in
emergency mode and it takes a lot of
energy
a lot of resources to live in emergency
mode all the time guess what system
becomes compromised by the immune system
your immune system why because you have
two Protection Systems you gotta you got
a system that protects you from dangers
in your outer world that's that's the
gas pedal that's the sympathetic nervous
system that's a fight or flight nervous
system danger threat out there use all
the energy because you gotta you gotta
survive and when you survive you got to
take care of your body so right so so
now
that system can work really well short
term
it doesn't work really well if you keep
it on all the time because if you're
mobilizing all that energy for some
thread in your outer world there's no
energy in your inner world for growth
and repair there's no energy for
long-term building projects and energy
leaves the brain and it leaves the heart
and it moves into these lower centers
because now you're tapping the body's
resources because there is an emergency
but whether the emergency is real or
imagined whether your anger is valid or
Justified or not
that the you're tapping the body's very
energy to heal by doing this and the
immune system says well we're part of
really the other nervous system we're
the break we're the clutch we need the
we need to get into relaxation we need
to get back into balance again and and
when we do then we'll metabolize then
we'll we'll assimilate we'll reproduce
we'll we'll excrete properly so so now
you got a this kind of battle between
the gas pedal and the brake and the
immune system says Hey listen if there's
foreign agents if there's viruses
bacteria molds funguses listen we don't
have a whole lot of energy here to deal
with them because we're fighting this
war out there there's no Homeland
Security so they shut down certain
receptors in the immune system they shut
down function of those lymphocytes those
white blood cells that are your inner
Army of protection and it takes a lot of
energy to fight a virus and a bacteria
but if there's no energy Hey listen it
takes energy to raise the body's
temperature what do you think that comes
from that's part of that branch called
the autonomic nervous system and the
sympathetic the gas pedal is part of it
and the parasympathetic is the clutch is
part of that autonomic nervous system
and it's a check and balance but so you
stay in emergency for an extended period
of time
and now you're exposed to some antigen
or some external substance some foreign
agent when we become the living example
of Truth when we actually embody this uh
that um there are no limits to what we
can do and I'm hopeful with human beings
that um that we have this capacity and
and of course when we believe in
ourselves we believe in possibility and
when we leave in possibilities we
believe in ourselves and I think that is
the ultimate belief
feelings and emotions are the end
product of past experiences
and you can remember experiences better
because you can remember how they feel
and when you're in the midst of an
experience
all of your senses plug you into the
environment
and as you're Gathering all of this
vital data from your external world
all that information rushes back to your
brain and it causes jungles of neurons
to organize themselves into Networks
the moment those neurons string into
place the brain makes a chemical and
that chemical is called a feeling or an
emotion
and once you feel that emotion you
create a long-term memory
now reason this with me
if feelings and emotions are the end
product of past experiences
and you are feeling the same way every
single day
doesn't that mean nothing new is
happening in your life
okay
and of those feelings and emotions Drive
certain thoughts
and you can't think greater than how you
feel
because you had events in your life that
have branded you emotionally
and you feel sadness or guilt or shame
or unworthiness or insecurity all of
those emotions are created from past
experiences
and when you feel those emotions
and those emotions Drive certain
thoughts
and then those thoughts make certain
chemicals for you to feel the same
emotion
and then those emotions Drive certain
thoughts
the repetition of that cycle then
conditions the body
to memorize that emotional state better
than the mind
and now your body literally is in the
past
because if you can't think greater than
how you feel then you are thinking in
the past
and so most people then spend the
majority of their life talking about why
they never arrive at their vision of the
future
because of some past experience
and so if feelings and emotions are the
end product of past experiences you
remember your first kiss you remember
your wedding you remember the birth of
your children you remember catching a
fish off the coast of manzanillo with
your three best friends
because you caught the fish and it was a
new experience and you felt great
and then you went to the Casita and you
cooked the mahi-mahi and you drank
Sauvignon Blanc and the wind was blowing
off the Sea and the sun was setting and
you made a long-term memory
[Music]
but you also have memories that are
connected to trauma and crisis
to disappointments
and those are the memories that people
remember more than anything else
and so if you haven't overcome some
emotion
that keeps you anchored to the Past
then you tell a story about the past
and people say I am this way because of
this experience that happened to me
15 years ago
I am this way because of some event that
happened 30 years ago
and from a biological perspective it
means I haven't been able to change in
the last 15 or 30 years
and Scientific American
a prestigious magazine
says that 50 percent of what you talk
about in your past isn't even the truth
you make it up
because you don't have the same brain
that you did 15 years ago or 30 years
ago
so then your brain and body are
typically in the past
because thoughts are the language of the
brain and feelings are the language of
the body
and how you think and how you feel
creates your state of being
so if you think insecure thoughts in a
matter of seconds you are going to feel
insecure
the moment you feel insecure
your brain is monitoring how you're
feeling and you think more insecure
thoughts which then makes you feel more
insecure
and the repetition of that cycle
conditions the body to become the mind
of insecurity
and then the person says I am insecure
and whenever you say I am anything you
are commanding your mind and body into a
destiny
so then how do people change
they wait for crisis trauma disease
diagnosis loss something has to go wrong
in their life
where they feel so uncomfortable that
they finally make up their mind to
change
and why is that
because after the trauma or the crisis
they don't feel like of themselves
and the moment they don't feel like
themselves they could actually observe
themselves
because they're looking at themselves
Through The Eyes of someone else
but my message is why wait
you can learn and change in a state of
pain and suffering
or you can learn and change in a state
of joy and inspiration memory is
creative that in fact fifty percent of
that story you embellish people make up
that story let me tell you why they make
up that story because they excuse
themselves for the fact that they
haven't been able to change
since that event they'll have to make it
sound worse than it really was to make
it harder to grow and change so that
they can reaffirm their limited sense of
their inability to change so then that
story becomes more and more of a story
and it's less of the truth because you
got to work yourself up into a state
there were lions and tigers and they
were right you know they were
helicopters snowstorms everybody was
firing bullets worse than you could
possibly imagine and then you've got to
feel that emotion right and then you
look at this oh yeah it must have been
really bad now that's that's your
identity now that's your identity if
your brain is a record of the past
and you were living by the same emotions
that have defined you for the last 10
years
and you keep thinking the same thoughts
that make the same chemicals and those
same chemicals Drive the same thoughts
then your body as the unconscious mind
does not know the difference between an
actual experience in your life that
creates an emotion
and an emotion that you're creating by
thought alone
and so your body is believing it's in
the same past experience 24 hours a day
seven days a week
365 days a year and your body is
programmed into the past
and you can create a new future holding
on to the emotions of the past
how many people understand what I'm
talking about
so then
when you react
to someone or something in your life
you have a choice
that when an event changes how you feel
there's a chemical change that's taking
place in your body
and most people don't think they can
control their emotional reactions
and so then when you react to some
co-worker or some relative or somebody
in traffic
the moment you react emotionally you
were altered chemically
and if you don't know how to control
your emotional reaction after that event
and you allow those emotions to linger
for hours or days
you know what that's called
that's called a mood
hey Juanito
what's wrong with you oh I'm in a mood
really
why are you in a mood
well this thing happened to me four days
ago
and I'm having one long emotional
reaction
and if you keep that same refractory
period going on for weeks or months
that's called a temperament
hey why is she so angry I don't know why
are you so angry why are you so bitter
why are you so enchilada
[Music]
because I had this experience
seven months ago
and I'm memorizing my emotional reaction
and if you keep that same refractory
period going on for years on end that's
called a personality trait
and people where their emotions on their
sleeve and that's who they think they
are
and they will talk about the past to
validate why they're not creating the
life that they want
so then if you wake up in the morning
Mexico City
and you are not being defined by a
vision that's bigger than you
and it doesn't get you out of bed and
inspire you into possibility
and you get up living from the old
Hardware of the past and the old
emotions stored in your body
do you know what's going to happen to
you
you're going to wake up and you're going
to open your eyes
and you're going to see the same people
and go to the same places and do the
exact same thing at the exact same time
and the moment you open your eyes all of
a sudden now it's your external
environment that's controlling how you
think and feel
because you have a neurological Network
in your brain for every person you know
every place that you go everything that
you own everything that you do
and the moment you open your eyes and
you see the same people and go to the
same places and do the exact same thing
at the exact same time it's your
external environment that's turning on
different circuits in your brain causing
you to think equal to everything that
you know
and you told me you believe that your
thoughts have something to do with your
destiny
and as long as you're thinking equal to
your environment you keep creating the
same life
change
to truly change is to think greater than
your environment
to think greater than the circumstances
in your life to think greater than the
conditions in your world in every great
person in history knew this
whether it was Mahatma Gandhi Martin
Luther King the Wright brothers Joan of
Arc
they all had a vision I always say to
people
when is the last time you sat with your
heart and just worked with it like so
that it's not contracted and Afraid and
protected it takes practice to to do
that and and so we we work with people
in letting them we give them numerous
opportunities to practice this over and
over and over again and sooner or later
pedal by pedal it starts to bloom and
all of a sudden there's an authentic
smile on their face and once energy
meets the heart it goes right to the
brain we have
we did this study where we hooked up an
electrocardiogram to an
electroencephalogram and an
electroencephalogram is a brain mapping
machine so we measure 19 or 26 different
compartments and we're looking to see
all different kind of activity in the
brain but we measure the heart along
with it and when the heart starts
beating coherently in a sense of order
like a like taking a big sheet J and
going like that the heart sends a wave
right up to the brain
and the Brain goes into these beautiful
states of alpha the heart is telling the
brain it's safe to create again it's
safe to imagine it's safe to dream of a
new future
and
there's the stroke volume of the heart
in order and then you see these two or
three seconds of beautiful coherent
Alpha the brain is in it's it's in that
creative state then there's a pause and
it happens again and yeah it's it's it's
Beauty it's a it's a symphony
if you don't have that mechanism you can
have all the intention in the world but
there's no carrier wave I mean and
people when they make energy reach their
heart there's an external field that's
created it's it's it's magnetic it's
it's it's measurable and that energy is
frequency and if that frequency is
coherent it can carry the intent
or thought on a coherent brain of that
future the energy of suffering cannot
carry the thought of health or wealth
it's not consistent with it it carries a
different set of thoughts
so then
the training then is getting people into
those hard States because once they
start trading that fear or that pain or
that frustration or trying or whatever
forcing you know control for gratitude
and they just let all that go and I say
to them listen if you can't feel
gratitude if you can't feel love I just
want to know what you've been practicing
feeling every day because that feeling
that you're practicing is what you're
always feeling now let's practice
feeling something else in the beginning
it's not going to be easy but you got to
keep following the formula keep doing it
keep doing it keep doing it well
when they start feeling gratitude it's
very interesting because
the emotional signature of gratitude
is that something wonderful just
happened to you something favorable is
happening to you right so you've just
received something or you're receiving
something you say Thank you so gratitude
is the ultimate state of receiving
emotionally
so when you move into a state of
gratitude and you open your heart you
will accept believe and surrender to the
thoughts equal to that emotional state
and you'll program your autonomic
nervous system into a different Destiny
you could say I'm healthy I'm healthy
I'm healthy I'm wealthy I'm wealthy I'm
wealthy I'm wealthy I'm free I'm free
I'm free and your body is conditioned in
the misery and it's saying no you're not
and that thought stops right at the
brain stem it never makes it to the body
because the body is on a different
program
so then when the person starts trading
that and they start opening their heart
well their immune system gets stronger
by 50 percent 50 percent in three days
they start making immunoglobulins their
body's natural defense against viruses
and bacterias 50 percent not a little
bit a lot that's that's one study and SO
trading that telling the body it's in
the in the environment where it already
happened and so that's when the Miracles
start happening that's when people say
I'm not doing anything well of course
you're not you don't have to what are a
few things we can do to support our
inner environment on a daily basis ah
well listen
um the first thing and the most
important thing for me is knowledge and
information
knowledge is really power and and
knowledge and information about yourself
shouldn't it should Empower you it
should empower the self right so when we
learn about the immune system and all
that can do and we say oh my God you
mean not every virus
gets to me in fact no and the more you
the more you understand that and the
more you coax your immune system into
love and into into like we well I just
did this little thing on um on our
social media where I was talking about
the inner Army of order what would be
the signal you would want that inner
Army to get and so we created this
meditation and we said what would
invincibility feel like signal your body
and feel Invincible how would you feel
if you had an uncompromising will that
you had more energy than you could
possibly imagine show your body what it
feels like because it is that emotion of
invincibility that emotion of an
uncompromising will to empower your
inner world and you have the intent of
that's what it's for Wow get ready
because you're going to start creating a
Cadence and a rhythm where your your
body's going whoa what what are the what
is all these new chemicals what are all
these new signals right hey it's time
hey okay uh now all of a sudden receptor
sites on the T cells go wow we got some
new signals coming from the boss here
let's open up all those T-cell receptors
let's go we in fact we're we're we would
love a little fight right now because we
got a lot of time on our hands and we
got all our receptors turned on oh I
mean that that would be
a signal for your body we also know that
if you could just trade fear and
frustration and resentment and suffering
for an elevated emotion and truly open
your heart again and practice doing that
um
you'll heal you'll heal you'll heal
because I mean all healings happen in
the heart can you believe in a future
that you can't see or experience with
your senses yet
but you've thought about enough times in
your mind that your brain is literally
changed to look like the event has
already occurred
the latest research in neuroscience
says you can change your brain from
living in the past to living in the
future
and can you fall in love with that
vision
to such a degree
that you come out of your resting state
and change guilt or suffering into
inspiration and joy and gratitude
to such a degree that your body as the
unconscious mind does not know the
difference between that external event
and what you're creating internally
so that your body believes it's living
in that future in the present moment and
you begin to Signal new genes in new
ways to change your body to look like
the event has already occurred
the latest research in epigenetics says
you can change your body by thought
alone
now reason this with me
if there's physical evidence in your
brain and body to look like the event
has already occurred
your brain and body are no longer living
in the past they're living in the future
and you will walk right into your vision
now most people in this audience
all of you
have done something great in your life
you all have
a reason this
you woke up one day or you had a wild
thought out of nowhere
and that thought was a possibility in
the future
something new you wanted to experience
and the moment you started thinking
about this experience the moment you
started contemplating
this potential reality
you turned on a part of your brain
called the frontal lobe
the crowning achievement of the human
being
it's 40 percent of your entire brain it
is the creative Center
and it has connections to all other
parts of the brain
and the moment you said what would it be
like to be a leader
what would it be like to be successful
what would it be like to have this
Vision come true
the moment you ask that open-ended
question
you turned on this part of the brain
because the rest of the brain is just a
bunch of automatic programs
and now the frontal lobe the creative
Center wakes up
and it has connections to the entire
brain it's the CEO it's the boss it's
the symphony leader of the brain
and the moment you get creative the
frontal lobe begins to select different
networks of neurons that are stored in
your brain from things you've learned or
experienced
and as you begin to think a what-if
question it begins to select these
different networks and begins to
seamlessly piece them together and
making your brain fire in new sequences
and in new patterns and new combinations
and whenever you make your brain work
differently you're changing your mind
because mind is the brain in action mind
is the brain at work
and the moment those neurons fire in
tandem
you get a picture in your mind a
hologram
a vision an abstraction
and for those people who are passionate
that thought that they're thinking
begins to create an elevated emotion
they become inspired
they feel enthusiastic in Theos filled
with God
they become passionate they started to
open their hearts
and all of a sudden they're combining a
clear intention with an elevated emotion
and it's the combination of a clear
intention and an elevated emotion in our
research over and over again that proves
then the person now is changing
fundamentally changing biologically
changing internally
and their brain and body are moving from
living in the past into living in the
future we have such compelling evidence
in science with brain scans you can make
your brain work better you can make your
heart work better you can make your
immune system work better you can make
your cells go from really sick to really
healthy we've got great evidence you can
become immune to Serious viruses you can
be immune in the bacteria we've got the
measurements if you can lengthen your
life
we have great evidence and people aren't
monks they're not they're not nuns
they're not religious Scholars they're
just common people and then we have
testimony
people who are the example of Truth they
are they are the example of truth I
would rather have dinner with those
people than anybody anybody else they
know something right
so evidence then becomes the loudest
voice right and and that's what I think
what people are looking for right now
the truth is so lost in sensationalism
and the truth is so lost in emotional
agreement and so people who want to feel
fear
they program themselves and accept
believe and surrender that people who
want to be hate be hateful
it's all there it's all there and it's
that it's a matrix to find the way out
right and and I think I think there's a
door I just I just think that we have to
trust the innate information that that
comes from within us people that were
traumatized from childhood that were
abused sexually physically emotionally
that were suicidal that had all kinds of
health conditions they came to the edge
of that emotion that kept them connected
to the past and they were ready to give
up in one meditation because
they they never had felt an emotion like
this that they could remember that it
was so intense
and they thought about all the times for
the last year that they never missed a
day of doing a meditation even when they
didn't feel like it or when they wanted
to quit halfway through and they didn't
they went all the way they thought about
all those times
that they went to that point and they
went one more time really and their
words are always the same and my heart
blew wide open and I looked back at my
entire past and I don't want to change
one thing in my past because it brought
me to this present moment and I can see
my betrayers I could see the people in
my life that had a hand in this and I
have nothing but compassion for them
because now the person is no longer
viewing that past from the same level of
Consciousness they're viewing it from a
place of Love of wholeness and they see
the greater good of all of it and now
they're they're they're
conditions their health conditions their
endometriosis their uterine tumors I
mean whatever it is literally
goes disappears and they have an
incredible incredible change in their
brain chemistry they're in love with
life they're off their meds they're not
suicidal they're why would they be
they're free so it can happen in an
instant when the heart is healed and
everybody gets the new signal the body's
out of the past the body's no longer
feeling the emotions of the past and
sometimes
we got to come right up against that
edge that's yeah that's the great moment
our immune system is kind of like our
rudimentary nervous system it has cells
that are mobile and they're called
plasma cells or white blood cells and
their job is an internal defense in many
of our bodies plasma cells uh line the
mucous membranes got the digestive tract
uh all the orifices of the body the nose
the mouth ears
and it's a line of defense against
foreign Invaders and toxins and when the
immune system is facing some foreign
Invader whether it be a virus a bacteria
a mold a fungus some foreign agent it is
the army of plasma cells that move
towards the danger and begin to attack
these foreign agents and
there are cells in your immune system
called t cells and T cells are like the
ninjas of the immune system they release
very powerful chemicals that can
denature and break down any foreign
Invader and T cells have these little
trumpets that stick out on the receptor
site so picture this big circular
spherical glob and you have all these
different receptors and these T cell
receptors are these long trumpet
appendages and when they come up to a
virus or they come up to a bacteria when
they come up to even a cancer cell
they notice that is a foreign agent and
immediately this T Cell receptor
attaches to that foreign agent and
begins to release a lot of unhealthy
chemicals that begin to cause that
foreign agent to to die and then
memorizes that foreign agent and passes
the information on to the army of the
rest of the white blood cells in the
body and and this is a strong immune
system and when plasma cells and white
blood cells
begin to function well they release
chemicals called immunoglobulins
and immunoglobulins are proteins that
are in the shape of a y and those
y-shaped proteins are antibodies and
what they do is when the the white blood
cell releases an antibody it begins to
block The receptors of the foreign agent
that's trying to attack the white blood
cells so when a healthy immunoglobulin
is released it suppresses the the
Warfare the the cell receptors that are
trying to attack the white blood cell
and now you have a strong defense you
have a strong immune system and at your
body right now is doing that in fact
your body is always evaluating all those
foreign agents whether it's a virus a
bacteria or even a cancer cell
and it's working to keep the body in
balance and the immune system a strong
healthy immune system does that
constantly always behind the scenes of
your awareness if you give people sound
information
and then they can repeat that
information
they're wiring it in their brain
they're creating a new model of
understanding
if you show them how to apply that
information
if they do it properly they will have
some type of transformation
that transformation isn't something that
causes people to feel bad or unworthy it
causes them to open their hearts
it causes them to feel Joy to feel
gratitude they feel differently
and if you're able to then create that
elevated emotion and you teach people
more information they will continue to
transform themselves and that's called
Evolution if you think the same thoughts
the same thoughts always lead to the
same choices the same choices lead to
the same behaviors the same behaviors
create the same experiences and the same
experiences produce the same feelings
and you're now caught in your old self
but new thoughts should lead to new
choices and new choices should lead to
new Behaviors new behaviors should
create new experiences and new
experiences should create new emotions
and that should Inspire evolution
we say that your personality creates
your personal reality
and your personality is made up of how
you think how you act and how you feel
we could say that your personality is
your state of being
so now geniuses
if you keep thinking the same thoughts
keep demonstrating the same behaviors
keep living by the same feelings and
emotions your personal reality is going
to stay exactly the same
but if you have new thoughts
that lead to new choices that
demonstrate new actions that create new
experiences that cause you to feel
differently you will begin to walk into
a new future how many people understand
this
so most people try to create a new
personal reality as the same personality
and it doesn't work you literally have
to become someone else
so crossing the river of change going
from the old self to the new self
requires you stepping into the unknown
and if you are now in the unknown and
you feel uncomfortable because you're
leaving guilt behind
you leave unworthiness behind you see
the biggest problem with most people
is they want to create wealth but they
feel lack
they want a new life but they feel
unworthy
that's Mind and Body in opposition
and our research shows that you can
teach people how to recondition their
body to a new mind
and when that occurs they begin to
create very powerful things in their
life what do you believe is the purpose
of life overall to figure out the
purpose of life okay I know I mean I
mean I really think it's I think the
mathematics that I've looked at says
there's infinite experiences to have you
will never know the end so then
if you study any religion I mean I've
looked at a lot of them this concept of
Eternity that the soul is going to be
around for eternity
that's a long time and that means you
got to be okay with you for a very long
time yeah so
I think it's I think it's the creation
of more experiences and I think to to I
think we came from Source from
Singularity from Oneness
yeah and we have descended down into
density a fooled by our Senses Into
separation and every single being has a
spark of Oneness of the divine within
them and we got so separate that we now
have our own free will to answer the
question is there more because if you're
Oneness it gets kind of boring after a
while like is there anything else well
moment you ask if there's anything else
you're no longer Oneness you're
something other than Oneness right and
you're a a different Consciousness
separate from Oneness
so I think then we live life and then
when we can predict the feeling of
everything that can happen in our life
and it gets boring and we're not
impressed by anyone or anything we ask
the same question
is there more and that's when the soul
goes ah right well it's been how many
lifetimes you've been doing this okay
there's an Awakening and the and we ask
that question and then all of a sudden
we start getting information and books
and stuff and meet people and it gets
exciting and and it's the it's it's How
the Universe works and so we climb out
of this and I just think there's so many
incredible experiences that are left in
the unknown uh that we get to have and
and then of course when
and the journey is over and you evolve
to that point uh then you take that
wisdom and you say here's what I learned
and it was scary down there and I was
like boy I tell a great story and then
you hang out there and you go
is there anything else besides all and
then here we go again it just never
Insider that's my theory how do we
brainwash ourselves in times of stress
and anxiety in order to become more
peaceful loving and successful in the
future how do we brainwash ourselves in
a different way sure
well um
that's what uh I've spent about my whole
life
and and
um wow I mean the first and most
important thing is that you have to
understand that if 95 of who you are is
a set of unconscious programs then the
first step is lighting a match in a dark
place if you want to become someone else
you got to become aware of who you are
yes that means you got to start thinking
about what you've been thinking about
you got to start paying attention to how
you speak got to be conscious you
demystify the word meditation and the
word meditation literally means become
familiar with yeah when you become so
familiar with your thoughts so aware of
your emotions so conscious of your
habits that you wouldn't go unconscious
to them again now you're no longer the
program right so so getting people
disentangled from that program we found
out as a formula and when we teach
people how to do certain things with
their focus and opening their awareness
when we teach them how to create a very
disorderly brain that has been driven by
the hormones of stress into a more
orderly coherent brain and teach them
how to open their focus and practice
that they'll come up against those
thoughts and they'll become so familiar
with them listen to this they won't
believe him anymore when they come up
any longer wow and so when they hear
them in their day they'll be like that's
not going to stop me from my future
so if they're sitting there and they
want to quit just because they're
sitting still
and they're not quitting then they're
developing a will that's greater than
those programs and you're breaking out
of the shell and you keep doing that
you're going to get up and do the work
every day because you did it yesterday
and you're going to want to do more of
that because you're getting out of your
past and it feels better and if you keep
doing that and you keep feeling better
every day the question is why wouldn't
you do it every day because you would
ultimately just feel better and then the
more whole you feel means the more you
are connected to your future imagine if
you felt every single day and this is
what I do work on
if I could stay connected to the
emotions of my future all day long
there's no way I would be looking for
when it would be happening how could I
look for when it would be happening if I
feel like it's happening I wouldn't look
anymore which means I wouldn't be
separate from it and that's when you
start creating the magic right that's
when you're in that zone and that's when
that reaffirms that personality that
you're becoming and now you don't you
know wake up in the morning oh God I
gotta create my future now you're you're
gonna jump out of bed excited you're not
going to want that magic to end how does
the person become the person they are
and why do they keep their health
condition the same and well most people
your brain is a record of the past it's
an artifact fact of everything you've
learned and experienced to this moment
so most people wake up in the morning if
you think that your thoughts have
something to do with your destiny they
start thinking about their problems and
those problems are just memories that
are etched in their brain that are
connected to certain people and objects
and certain things at certain times and
places and the moment they start
thinking about their problems or
thinking in the past now because every
one of those problems has an emotion
associated with them
the moment they start feeling unhappy or
feeling sad now their bodies in the past
because thoughts are the language of the
brain and feelings of the language of
the body and how we think and how we
feel creates our state of being though
the problem is is that the person thinks
of the problem feels the emotion and
that is a thought and feeling that's a
image and an emotion it's a stimulus and
response and that starts the
conditioning process to get the body
emotionally conditioned into the past
now here's the crazy part about it yes
but a familiar past
emotionally
is producing dramatic effects on the
body because the body is so objective
that it does not know the difference
between the real life experience that's
creating that emotion and the emotion
that person is fabricating by thought
our memory alone the body's believing
it's living in the same past experience
seven days a week 365 days a year and
the problem with that is is that the
environment signals the gene that's
epigenetics and the end product of an
experience and the environment there's
an emotion so the person is keeping the
same gene regulated because the body's
believing it's living in the same
environmental condition so
getting that person to step outside of
that familiar known territory into the
unknown
where there is uncertainty and have them
be comfortable there and begin to think
about how they are going to think the
new model of reality is about causing an
effect
that means then you have to feel
gratitude every day for your new
experience to occur
you can't wait for your success to feel
empowered
you have to be empowered to create the
success
and when you teach people how to do this
and they move into a new state of being
they begin to create the life that they
want
how many people are still with me
but to the materialists they would say
well no
no no no I'm gonna wait for my money to
come and then I'm going to give thanks
and those people pretty much are living
by the emotions of the past
and if you're living by the emotions of
the past you were viewing your future
through the lens of the past and your
vision will fade
because when you bring up an elevated
emotion you will see the vision clearly
and leaders in history that change the
world knew how to change a culture look
at Martin Luther King
he talked about Justice and then got
enough people inspired that they felt
empowered enough to do something about
it
people came out of their resting state
and so then you share the same brain as
Martin Luther King
and being defined by a vision of the
future begins to change a culture
but most people have the same thoughts
or the same intentions and they live by
the same familiar emotions and for the
most part they're in their past love
inspires us it inspires us to give it
inspires us to express it inspires us to
serve to care for one another to be kind
to one another to listen with compassion
and understanding and love actually
causes us to create we become creative
in that state
and you've heard me say that when there
is a change in energy there's a change
in your life and and inspiration is a
change in energy
and if you don't change your energy if
you stay in the same energy then it
makes sense that your life stays the
same
so if you can become inspired and raise
your energy you become aware of things
that you were once unaware of why
because
energy causes us to become conscious of
things we are once unconscious to in
other words you change your frequency
you have more access to information and
that's the name of the game here so
if you stay at the same level of energy
every single day then you will be
unaware of possibilities so you'll
you'll not be able to create anything
new
so you can't see any possibilities again
from the same energy in order for you to
become inspired by love inspired by
energy you'll become conscious of
possibilities that you were once
unconscious of
now
energy or energy in motion uh they are
emotions and so if we live by the same
emotions every single day and we haven't
changed Who We Are
and there's a movement happening where
you're in the creative state
and you stay in the same feelings in the
same familiar emotions then you can't
see any possibilities because you're
looking through the lens of some past
experience and you can only see the same
so then
inspiration then the word inspiration
means
the movement of energy
inspiration to inspire in spirit it is
becoming more energy and less matter the
future then is created by a clear
intention and an elevated emotion now
listen closely that you have to
cultivate in your inner environment of
thoughts and feelings
but most people
by the old self are living from past
memories that are created from knowledge
and experience from something that
happened outside of them
some experience or trauma that defined
them
and getting a person beyond the old self
then is the great work that's what we're
here for
so
we've studied motivation
and I can tell you without a doubt
that the highest form of motivation
in any culture
in any group of people is what's called
purpose motivation Duty motivation or
Mission motivation you know what that is
to have a vision to change a culture
that's bigger than you to instill change
in the world look at Elon Musk how many
people know who he is
Elon Musk he created Tesla Motors
you know him you know who he is
he created an electric car
that can go from 0 to 60 in less than
five seconds
and before him electric cars were like
golf carts
that CR you know crawled along the road
and he said I'm going to do this I don't
know how I'm going to do it but I have a
vision
and I'm going to get the best engineers
in the world and instead of creating a
new product and selling it to a
corporation
I'm going to get a group of people to
share the same vision as me I'm going to
change the world by changing our
Reliance on oil
and I am going to make a difference in
the world and I am going to make a lot
of money
why not
and so people said no that's not
possible and he held on to that vision
and now Motor Trend Magazine never
raided a car a close to a hundred
they rated the Tesla car 103.
it's the best car on the road
and it relies on no gas at all that's a
vision of the future I got run over by a
truck and and I broke 64 debris my spine
and I had to make a decision at that
time in my life um because the diagnosis
wasn't very good and neither was the
prognosis and decide if I was going to
spend the rest of my life on addictive
medications and both surgical rods in my
spine or if I was going to see if the
mind could actually heal the body and so
that was my wake-up call in 1986 and so
so I just
um I was at the point where I just had
to make a decision to see if it was
actually the truth if if all of this
that I learned was the truth let's let's
apply it and so I was lucky enough to
have a dramatic change in my own
personal health and then I thought God
yeah if it worked on me as it worked on
other people so I started looking into
people that had you know been treating
conventionally or non-conventionally and
and with a certain diagnosis and their
condition was staying the same getting
worse and all of a sudden it got better
and and I just wanted to look at what
the cause was that was producing that
effect and so
I interviewed you know hundreds and
hundreds of people that had gone through
the process and one of the most
fundamental elements that they all had
in common with there were a lot of
things that had to do with their mind
and uh and some people had specific
diets and specific regimes some people
use certain
um you know conventional
non-conventional protocols but the the
commonality primarily was about how the
mind was really influencing the body and
and
they began to really take a closer look
at how they were thinking on a daily
basis how they were acting on a regular
basis and looking at how they feel uh on
a moment-to-moment basis and and how you
think and how you act and how you feel
is your personality and your personality
has a very direct relationship with your
personal reality which means if you want
to change your personal reality if you
want to change something about your life
you got to change and so the process of
change then becomes the fundamental
process of going from some person that's
familiar and known to you and stepping
out and beginning to make different
choices and to begin thinking different
thinking differently and be into behave
differently and speak differently and
feel differently and and if you start
thinking acting and feeling differently
our research shows without a doubt
you're going to have dramatic changes in
your biology and if you do it enough
times you're going to become someone
else and the disease then all of a
sudden exists in the old personality and
not in the new personality and then you
ask the person where's the cancer
where's the rheumatoid arthritis where's
the immune mediated condition uh it's in
the old person I'm not that person any
longer if you have been an experienced
if you had experience of trauma say for
example and it's created the feeling of
fear and your fears that it could happen
again
and you're you don't know this but every
time you think about that future that
possible worst case scenario scenario
and you feel the emotion you're
conditioning your body to become the
Mind subconsciously of anxiety
so now all you need now is some cue in
your outer environment that says it's
unsafe that if there's damage there that
you're you're a victim something's
bigger than you that could have an
effect on you well now that feeling of
fear is going to cause you to think
thoughts equal to it so the person then
no longer needs the environment to feel
that fear they just have to have the
thought about that condition now and now
they're literally knocking their brain
and body out of balance by thought alone
and the body's constantly living in
emergency mode and it takes a lot of
energy
a lot of resources to live in emergency
mode all the time guess what system
becomes compromised by the immune system
your immune system why because you have
two Protection Systems you gotta you got
a system that protects you from dangers
in your outer world that's that's the
gas pedal that's the sympathetic nervous
system that's a fight or flight nervous
system danger threat out there use all
the energy because you gotta you gotta
survive and when you survive you got to
take care of your body so right so so
now
that system can work really well short
term
it doesn't work really well if you keep
it on all the time because if you're
mobilizing all that energy for some
threat in your outer world there's no
energy in your inner world for growth
and repair there's no energy for
long-term building projects and energy
leaves the brain and it leaves the heart
and it moves into these lower centers
because now you're tapping the body's
resources because there is an emergency
but whether the emergency is real or
imagined whether your anger is valid or
Justified or not
that you're tapping the body's very
energy to heal by doing this and the
immune system says well we're part of
really the other nervous system we're
the break we're the clutch we need the
we need to get into relaxation we need
to get back into balance again and and
when we do then we'll metabolize then
we'll we'll assimilate we'll reproduce
we'll we'll excrete properly so so now
you got a this kind of battle between
the gas pedal and the brake and the
immune system says Hey listen if there's
foreign agents if there's viruses
bacteria molds funguses listen we don't
have a whole lot of energy here to deal
with them because we're fighting this
war out there there's no Homeland
Security so they shut down certain
receptors in the immune system they shut
down function of those lymphocytes those
white blood cells that are your inner
Army of protection and it takes a lot of
energy to fight a virus and a bacteria
but if there's no energy Hey listen it
takes energy to raise the body's
temperature what do you think that comes
from that's part of that branch called
the autonomic nervous system and the
sympathetic the gas pedal is part of it
and the parasympathetic is the clutch is
part of that autonomic nervous system
and it's a check and balance let's talk
about the Neuroscience of culture
because there is a neuroscience to it
you have a brain that looks just like
the person sitting next to you
and if I was to screw off the top of
your heads
and take out your brain and your
partner's brain someone sitting next to
you and I went like this
and I set them out you probably wouldn't
be able to tell them apart
because you share the same structure in
your brain and we call that Universal
traits we call it gross anatomy now
because you share the same brain as the
person sitting next to you you smile
when you're happy you frown when you're
sad you sleep at night wow this is
Mexico you sleep kind of late at night
and get up kind of late in the morning
come on I'm kidding
and you know you grab a stick the same
way we speak a language and because we
share the same gross anatomy of the
brain we have very Universal traits that
we have in common how many people are
with me
but now
how your brain is wired
is your individuality and that's the
minute architecture or the minute
structure of the brain
so then
your brain is wired different than the
person next to you because you have
different experiences but if you share
the same experiences because you're in a
relationship then you have similar
brains that are kind of relating and
relationships are built on common
experiences if we share the same
experiences we share the same emotions
and if we share the same emotions we can
relate with each other
so then think about it like this
you have a hand
and because you have a hand you you have
the same hand as the person next to you
there's only a certain amount of things
you can do with your hand
but now
what makes you unique is your
fingerprint that gives you your
individuality and that is really the
minute anatomy of something related to a
hand are you with me
so now what is the division that unifies
both the universal traits and our
individual traits
and the answer is culture
and culture is defined by the
environment in which you live
the environment in which you work the
environment of your family
an environment is made up of just a few
things are you ready people
objects things places time pets and
that's pretty much your environment so
the culture of Mexico City
is defined by the environment
you eat certain foods you like certain
music you relate with one another
because of the environment in which you
live in
and that culture is Created from the
environment which is different than the
culture of Mongolia
because it's a different environment and
they have different Traditions they have
different Customs because they've had to
survive in a different environment and
so what unifies individual individual
traits and Universal traits is called
culture now think about this
most cultures are defined by the Customs
they have the Traditions the language
their survival skills their habits their
attitudes their beliefs their history
their Arts their social structures that
have unified them as an individual
culture
are you still with me
so the people you work with the people
you relate with the people you interact
with you share a similar culture that
bonds you both as an individual and as a
species called human beings
and Mexicans are different than
Australians because they live in a
different environment and they have
different Traditions you're still with
me but we could say then that culture
typically is defined by things that have
worked in the past
so then
most cultures then
have a choice
to create a new culture means then you
have to Define your culture as a vision
of the future
but most people their cultures are based
on the past present reality what does
that mean we are in a changing world
and the world is changing faster than
most people can keep up
and if you are going to stay defined by
a memory of the past you will not keep
up with this culture because we are
creating a global culture
so then
what defines the vision of the future to
change a culture
and the answer is a very clear intention
a clear purpose combined with an
elevated emotion
and when you combine a clear intention
like a vision of the future
along with an elevated emotion of
inspiration and joy you will create an
empowered individual what's something
that you've said in the past that you
were confident about it then but now
upon reflection you're like all right
I've changed my mind about that oh that
it takes a long time to create reality
I'm going to ask you to expand on that
because I like that answer I want to
know more that's fascinating
well um I think just like anything else
uh you learn how to snowboard you go
through that learning curve you learn
how to ride a bike you go through that
learning curve uh that that I used to
think that creation was hard I just
thought it took a lot of energy and it
took a lot of sacrifice and you had to
work for it and crayons and uh oh God I
mean even my definition of surrender
today is very different than it was just
three months ago because I'm always
doing it and so I think that it doesn't
have to be that way I just think that it
could be any way you want and that and
I'm working on that changing that belief
personal conviction motivation we call
these people self-starters this is
entrepreneurial motivation
this is when you say
I'm going to do this because I said I
was going to do it
still a high form of motivation but not
the highest form
but what we know that people who have
purpose motivation naturally are
personally convicted
their their personal conviction is in
alignment with their purpose because
they have a reason to get up every day
if someone is so disconnected to their
future their greater future self if
they're so
uh negative thoughts Suicidal Thoughts
often uh hurting themselves potentially
often what can they start to do to just
give someone a little bit of relief and
peace in their heart yeah it's simple
knowledge
experience wisdom
philosophy initiate that philosophy
Master it yep Mind Body Soul thinking
doing being learning with your head
applying it with your hands knowing it
by heart and this is the Journey of
knowledge because when you learn that
information and you really study it you
are going to begin to see the world
differently because your brain is
changing then when you start saying how
can I use this how can I apply it how
can I personalize it how could I do
something initiate this information what
do I got to do how do I get my behaviors
to match my intentions now this is the
act of trial and error it's so important
you don't make it the first time you
don't give up you get up and you try to
walk again
and you start learning how to do this
and so as you begin to do it over and
over again you start having new
experiences yes well new experiences
enrich the circuits in your brain
philosophically and now the brain makes
a chemical and now you're feeling more
unlimited you're feeling more whole
you're teaching your body chemically to
understand what your mind intellectually
understood and now you are literally
literally starting to embody that
knowledge it's becoming it's signaling
new Jesus it's new information but but
you can't do it one day and expect your
wealth to come you gotta do it over and
over again yeah so the repetition of
practicing over and over again
neurochemically conditions the mind and
body begin to work as one you've done it
so many times the body now knows how to
do it subconsciously just like it just
like I knew how to subconsciously lean
into trauma and victim mode right
decades now the body's getting new
information it's going to adapt and and
now you're going to literally become
that knowledge you're going to be coming
that's what you're going to become and
so now that's when you no longer have to
try it's who you are it's yes yeah
you've memorized an internal order
that's greater than anything in your
outer world that's going to tell you
something else that's key right there I
was looking uh closely and there are
people
that do this work do do this
transformation work in the meditations
that we teach and they're so impatient
and they're so entitled uh and they want
an instantaneous change from the lack of
their feelings right that they never
overcome themselves in their meditation
they never overcome themselves in the
meditation and when they finish their
meditation they believe in this work
less then there are people who say I can
tell you the moment I made up my mind to
change
because I had reached the end and I made
a decision and that decision to change
carried an amplitude of energy that was
greater than the hardwired programs in
my brain and the emotional conditioning
in my body and my body literally
responded to my mind in that moment that
the choice that I made became a moment
in time I would never forget and they'll
tell you and that's the moment I
remembered when I was going to change
now
those people then when they sit down to
do the work their the chemotherapy
hasn't worked
uh the injections didn't work uh the
radiation didn't work uh the surgery
didn't work the diet didn't work the
yoga didn't work this is this is now
their end they have nothing else to
believe in but themselves and they go
all in not 50 not 60 they're going all
in they have nothing else to believe in
now listen
when they go a little bit outside the
known they've got they went a little
further than where they normally would
stop they push themselves to that next
limit
they started believing in themselves
that they could do it a little bit more
they they finished the meditation and
they get up and believing it's it's it's
working more than working less that
they're the person that's believing in
themselves that's why because it's not
the work it's your belief in yourself
right it's and then when you believe in
yourself you believe in possibilities
When You Believe in possibilities you
got to believe in yourself
to the materialist who's waiting for
their wealth to show up to feel abundant
they're in their past
the person who's waiting for the success
to feel empowered is in their past
the person who's waiting for their
healing to feel wholeness
they're in their past
the person who's waiting for the riches
to come to feel gratitude they're in
their past they're materialists
in other words
you have to feel empowered in order for
your success to show up
you have to feel abundant for your
wealth to find you
you have to be in gratitude for you to
create the life that you want
and by you teaching your body
emotionally what that future could feel
like ahead of the actual experience
is changing your biology
because most people wait for something
outside of them to change how they feel
inside of them if something outside of
you is controlling your feelings and
thoughts then it makes you a victim to
your environment so then so you will be
more victimized or more you could be
more of a victim to other things in your
environment people don't understand this
consciously because it's a program
subconsciously
so so now
if you begin to strengthen your inner
environment now this is where our work
comes in because we have research to
show
that when you place your attention right
here in your heart this center right
here this is this is the beginning of
our Divinity this is our Center of
Oneness our wholeness this is where we
begin to feel love gratitude compassion
kindness care Freedom Joy it's all these
elevated emotions that are heartfelt
emotions that our research shows
that when you begin to teach people how
to open the center
and you teach them a formula on how to
practice it that if they did that for
four days
that
they would begin to strengthen their
immune system by 50 and now let me tell
you why because in the center is your
heart but what most people don't know
there's another gland in there called
the thymus gland fine Leaf it's named
after the the thought the time leaf and
the thymus gland has two functions it
has an endocrinological function it
makes growth hormone that's our youth
center and it makes a strong immune
chemicals and it has an immunological
function so when you're living by stress
and your heart is racing and you're
stepping on the gas and the brake at the
same time because you can't run You
Can't Fight You Can't Hide and you got
the gas and the clutch come on energy is
going to leave the harness go into the
adrenal Center and you're going to cause
contraction in the arteries in your
heart and the center will shut down from
blood flow and so
there's no energy in the heart so you
teach a person then how to begin to open
the center and to start feeling elevated
emotions through their heart
and you teach them how to switch or
convert from the sympathetic nervous
system to the parasympathetic nervous
system while all of a sudden now this
thymus gland which normally shrinks with
age of starting at puberty the Fountain
of Youth now all of a sudden begins to
get new blood flow and there's new
hormones that are signaled like oxytocin
and vasopressin and all these different
chemicals called
um nitric oxide and endothelial derived
relaxing factor and the arteries in the
heart begin to swell with energy and
blood flow and this center switch is on
and now it says man this feels good and
this is a time for us to really get back
into balance and really let's strengthen
our inner world now and now all of a
sudden this thymus gland begins to make
thymosine which is an important agent
that begins to make T cells and T cells
have little receptors on them called T
cell receptors and when those T cell
receptors are robust and strong those
cells make proteins and they make what's
called antibodies or immune
immunoglobulins and these little
y-shaped proteins block The receptors
coming from the virus that are trying to
attack the white blood cells they have a
shield and now their their immune to the
to the virus and its attack with its
receptor and it can literally begin to
inject it with these immunoglobulins
primary immunoglobulin a and that begins
to cause the virus to not survive wow
and then that white blood cell will pass
another white blood cell and pass on the
memory to it so it already knows what's
coming so now
all of a sudden you're making these
immunoglobulins and now your inner world
now can combat anything that's that's a
foreign agent and even cancer cells I
have three kids and I've raised my kids
with these principles and and I think uh
there are critical periods Ed where
certain information uh is more
understood
in certain periods where uh you can you
can really Advance a teaching or an
understanding but the children you know
their first six years of their life
they're very suggestible to information
and their brain waves are just in a
slower pattern so they don't have any
critical facilities or analytical
facilities so big boys don't cry little
girls should be seen and not heard money
is the root of all evil God is mad at
you you're going to go to hell so kids
just take that all in without any filter
and that becomes the foundation of their
personality and our identity then you
throw in parents
there are 95 percent of the time running
unconscious programs while children have
mirror neurons and mirror neurons
emulate Behavior so when you're feeding
your kids when they were young you took
that spoon and you went like this
you didn't know you were doing that but
you were doing that and they were
watching you and you were watching them
and they were they were turning on the
same circuits in their brain that you
were turning on just so they could model
the behavior so so then you can't say
the kid stop being an emotional basket
case because you're not listening to
anything you're saying they're they're
observing Behavior so when a lioness
takes her Cubs out to hunt they sit and
they watch her and they're when they're
watching her she's priming their brain
they're actually going to emulate her
behavior so as they start observing her
they start turning on the same circuits
they will when they hunt so they start
imprinting it right
so then with children then
I call it the fast path to Enlightenment
because if you want to raise a great kid
you got to be the example and so
um you know there's certain principles
with children uh in certain critical
periods you don't tell your kids when
they're four years old you create your
reality fix this you know it's not
they're not ready for that but there are
certain things at certain periods of
time that are really healthy and and
teaching children how to shorten
refractory period of their emotional
reactions is so important in simple
things like a trampoline
is a great way when a kid is upset
just change their stage let's go yeah
let's go okay and they jump and you jump
with them 10 minutes later
it's gone isn't that true and so then
you're teaching them that kind of
emotional intelligence
parents need to know that it's so
important to understand to never
rationalize with your kid when they're
emotional
why because do you want to hear anything
when you're emotional or do you want to
be left alone because no new information
can enter their nervous system that is
not equal to the emotion that they're
experiencing it's not relevant
so then getting them past their
emotional state and teaching them how to
shorten their refractory period and then
timing
okay but they start getting ready for
bed and it's getting loving and it's
getting quiet and they're settling down
and get in bed with them and you lay
there and you say you know I had a tough
day today I've been working on my
frustration you know and I didn't do
very well today I just I got angry at a
few points I got frustrated and I stayed
that way for like three hours and you
just opened the door for kids and
they'll say yeah you know I was playing
the day you know they'll automatically
said and I got so frustrated with my
friend Paris you know and I'll say well
that's all right you know that's normal
we all do that but what I care about the
most
is that if you had another opportunity
tomorrow in the same situation how would
you do it better oh my God and then
they'll say well I would do this and
then you say really if you do that this
is probably going to happen so let's
work on this together so you start
building a model
and you help them because they're so
neuroplastic and then once you get that
model in place then you say to them
tell me how to do it again what would
you do now what are they doing they're
rehearsing and so now they're installing
circuitry and then you say one more time
one more time because you forgot that
one part and you'd be surprised because
they're in that right suggestible State
and then get the model down and then you
say okay I'm going to tell you a story
there was these two kids a boy and a
girl does he have a boy and a girl right
and they lived in this magic land and if
they're young there's castles and and
there's dragons and this little girl had
a best friend you know when you tell the
whole story and she was making this
reaction the same time in the same way
and all of a sudden you know she just
decided to do something differently and
then you repeat it and then you say we
know what happened she wound up being
happier and more loving to herself and
more loving with everybody else and you
know your kids will go
was that me and you say I don't know so
then you're planting the seed because
you made it this far in a video I want
to celebrate you most people start and
don't finish most people never actually
follow through most people say they want
something but they don't ever do the
work to actually get it but you're
different you are special believe Nation
you made it here all the way to the end
and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for 10
more amazing rules from John Assaraf
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there a lot of athletes
have this term around the a game and
showing up and doing their absolute best
mentally emotionally physically
spiritually Etc and it got me thinking
about do you even know what your age